there are many ways in which we can find
the HC F of two numbers but in this
video we will look at the prime factor
method let's say we want to find the HC
f of 24 and 36 what we need to do is
very simple
we just have to reduce the numbers to
its prime factors and we can do that
using upside-down division first let's
find the prime factors of 24 we draw two
lines like this now we think of all the
prime factors that 24 is divisible by we
start with 2 24 is divisible by 2 so we
write a 2 here 2 times 12 is 24
what about 12 is it divisible by 2 yes
12 is also divisible by 2 we write 2
again and draw a line 2 times 6 is 12 6
is also divisible by 2 and 2 times 3 is
6 we stop here as we got a prime factor
how can we write 24 now remember the
l-shape 24 can be written as 2 x 2 x 2 x
3 we reduce 24 to its prime factors we
do the same for 36 actually why don't
you try reducing 36 to its prime factors
pause the video and give it a shot 36 is
divisible by 2 and 2 times 18 is 36 18
is also divisible by 2 and 2 times 9 is
18 is 9 divisible by 2
no 9 is not divisible by 2 and we jump
to the next prime number which is 3 is 9
divisible by 3 yes 9 is divisible by 3 3
times 3 is 9 we stop here since it's a
prime factor 36 can be written as the
product of these 4 numbers 36 is equal
to 2 multiplied by 2
x 3 x 3 the difficult part is over but
how does this give us the HCF to find
the 8 CF all we have to do is multiply
the prime factors that are common to
both the numbers 2 is a common prime
factor to both the numbers so we write a
2 once there is another 2 that is common
to both so we multiply this 2 with
another 2 and there is a 3 which is
common to both the numbers as well hence
we multiply this product with 3 yes we
just multiplied the prime factors which
are common to both the numbers this
gives us the HCF 2 times 2 is 4 and 4
times 3 is 12 the highest common factor
of 24 and 36 is 12 this is the prime
factor method to find the highest common
factor of two numbers in the next
session we will solve for the 8 CF of 42
and 56
[Music]
you